hello
is this the legendary one and only
dennis prager
i'll get him i'll get him connected
venice how are you how you doing
i'm probably doing uh as well as much of
the country i'm nervous
i'm i'm you know i'm nervous with hope
nervous with hope so you're watching all
the scores you're watching all the
things that's coming up texas
florida pennsylvania north carolina
arizona how are you feeling about it
tonight
well uh hugh hewitt is calling and i
would like to
talk to him um the uh sorry about that
the how am i feeling okay uh i'm worried
about
this notion this utterly irresponsible
notion
that in pennsylvania and georgia they
stopped counting at 10 30
so that they could go to have a nice
night's sleep like they don't owe it to
the country
kidding this is 100 right they should be
a joke
they stopped counting that ten cents
right
correct and pennsylvania's rule that
they could count ballots
until friday what that is infuriating
yeah no kidding
two rogue states that that's why i'm
telling you i don't think we don't know
so so that what you said pennsylvania
dennis and what was the other state
georgia
so then here's a question for you can we
find out results without those two
states
uh that's that's it's possible it
depends on michigan wisconsin
uh and and uh uh even maybe even
minnesota
look what the only other absolutely
clear thing
is that the pollsters were wrong again
uh yeah trump may not win but
uh the pollsters look absurd and i don't
know why people take them seriously
um it's like a it's like
voodoo dennis you've been you've been
around the politics
around politics for a while how often
have you seen states just to sign the
middle of the night we're not going to
count tonight
uh i i don't recall this happening i
don't recall a lot of things i don't
recall in the history of america
people who who didn't sign up to uh get
an absentee ballot
tens of millions of people get ballots
in the mail
i know so many individual cases of a
gone awry my friends daughters
moved from california like eight years
ago to
texas they got ballots in california and
ballots in texas
wow so do do you think there can be
other states tonight like in michigan or
wisconsin that can just say
we're not counting tonight until
tomorrow or the next day
if it if in fact it's that close
and they haven't done the uh the mail-in
ballots that's probably what they'll
announce
can they legally do that
states can do whatever they want it i
mean it's the advantage and disadvantage
of the system i
i prefer states having power
but when democrats run states you get
corruption
that is there is no exception to that
rule of which i know
and uh this is another example yeah what
are they going to do with those ballots
overnight
that would that's my concern wow
my concern is that they'll figure out
where them
do you ever notice that whenever they
find ballots in close races they're
always democratic ballots
they never find republican ballots they
never get lost isn't that astonishing
so you sound very optimistic no
i i am i said i'm i have hope
and uh let's put it this way i i was um
i was utterly pessimistic four years ago
i am more optimistic uh this time so for
whatever that's worth
uh i have a theory that optimism and
pessimism are
both worthless but uh
when we i'll i'll happily go on your
your uh podcast and give my theory on
pessimism and optimism and their
worthlessness
why i definitely look forward to that
because when when you talk
you you you make the mind work because
you
your is always a little bit different
but here's the last question for you
before we let you go and you can go on
hugh hewitt
what is the biggest difference in your
opinion between a biden
2020 versus a hillary 2016.
uh there's there's no difference the
democrats have become a left-wing party
in in the last 20 years they are not a
liberal parties they were liberal party
i would still vote republican
but i i i would be able to sleep at
night i i didn't i
didn't stay up all night when bill
clinton won i i didn't vote for him but
i
you know sophie and he was a liberal he
wasn't a leftist
uh but now uh now it's the destroy
america party versus the republicans
that's that's the that's the difference
so that's what you're calling the left
uh because i just wanted for our
listeners to understand exactly this is
ray crockett two-time super bowl uh
champion with the denver broncos ray
crockett go ahead ray
and i just wanted you to clarify more of
what you're calling a left wing just
so that we know why did you not sleep
because of
okay because of the left uh all over the
world the left
uh hates america the the american left
is no different
and the proof is the the example the
1619
lie of the new york times that will be
taught to almost all school children in
america
america was founded to uh to have
slavery
that was its purpose the the revolution
did not start america slavery started
america
uh the the idea that uh america is
founded
in slavery for every country on earth
every every ethnicity every race
every religion has slaves every single
one but
they they single out america because
they hate it uh brazil got 12 million
slaves america got 360 000 slaves
are they attacking brazil no because
brazil is not a threat to the left
america is a threat to the left because
america is a capitalist success
it is a religious success everything
they ate we've been successful in
who's they who's who's the left yeah
because i i i like
the left is the people who uh who
consider
america needing fundamental
transformation
they are people who do not believe in
the
excellence of capitalism they and and
most even bigger than that
they do not believe in free speech the
left
since lenin there is no exception i've
studied the left my whole life
the left has always there is no
exception
suppressed free speech wherever and
whenever it has power
from vladimir lenin and the russian
revolution uh to the university campus
in the united states today
to google youtube's uh uh instagram
uh and uh facebook and twitter what is
the worst
you're saying that big tech is the
current leftists
insofar as free speech is concerned
absolutely
okay i just want to know who you mean by
that yeah what about
and protection it's a very fair question
i'll answer everything you ask
does speech and protest go the same i'm
sorry the speech and protests are
is that the same as far as your freedoms
yeah you're totally free to protest in
the united states that nobody nobody has
and everybody nobody says no you're not
free to riot you're not free to loot
you're not free to burn you're not free
to smash
but you're certainly free to protest
that so why whatever
why would they why were the republicans
so upset at the free
protesting that colin kaepernick started
then
because he was ruining the sport and and
uh and uh they weren't against they
never said he wasn't free to do it
you're free to burn the american flag as
far as we're concerned what if colin
kaepernick could burn the flag before a
game
is he free to do so absolutely free free
doesn't mean you should do it
okay this is the first time in american
history that sports have been
politicized
what a lot of people a lot of people
took the knee who are pro-life a lot of
pro-life athletes
america has abortion i'm not going to
stand for the national anthem
i'd be just as i would be just as upset
i do agree with the hypocrisy i think
that obviously tim tebow is a good
uh correlation to make there and he was
given
incredible amounts of scrutiny for
you know worshiping his savior you know
and um
and then you know and he still did it
but
you know now you know everybody's saying
well colin kaepernick should be able to
do it and i think there's a massive
amount of hypocrisy
there but um i don't you know i i do
think that we need to be really careful
in our in our professional sports about
what we align with i mean you know like
so professional sports in history right
they've aligned with you know breast
cancer right everybody wears pink
they've aligned with lou gehrig's
disease in baseball right
but when you start to bring in an
organization like black lives matter and
you have to be able to compartmentalize
this once again there has to be logic
here right so
is the black lives matter movement
important
yes but the organization is crap
okay so i want somebody i've been asking
this for weeks i've been asking this for
actually months i want somebody to show
me
all the massive amounts of money that
black lives matter has raised i want you
to show me one black family
that's benefited from it i want you to
show me a scholarship
i want you to show me uh a house what do
you think about that what do you think
about working yeah
so true let me make it very clear the
left cares about blacks as much as
communist cares about workers
communists use workers to get into power
and then they craft on the workers
the left doesn't care about any group it
uses them to gain power
the left doesn't care about women the
proof is that when biological men
race against biological women in high
school sports
uh they think it's fair uh they don't
care
it's been on issue with protecting women
uh
the elementary right to race against uh
people of your own sex uh the
uh the the communists or the left is
always used groups
the president has done more for blacks
if you care about blacks you should have
voted for the republicans
if you care about being angry then you
should vote for the democrats
so the question is if i am a black i
have two choices do i want a better life
or do i want to [ __ ] on america
[Music]
and the republicans give a better life
how
oh because it's the lowest black
unemployment rate because it does
it says we are not going to lower
standards for blacks because unlike
unlike the left
we believe blacks are just as capable as
every other group in america to succeed
if they work hard but if you say people
should work hard according to the left
you are now a racist
if you say that you're colorblind
according to the left you are now a
racist
if you say there shouldn't be all black
dormitories according to the
left you are now a racist every liberal
idea
is opposed by by the left they believe
in all black dorms notice the ku klux
klan
hmm i can't say that i
got that from the left but
[Applause]
i mean you you say you know a lot of me
maybe you know a
i haven't really fully heard a lot
name names would you you're saying they
you're saying leftists you're saying
that the new york times
the new yorkers
charles and blow uh columnist new york
times does it mean anything to you
the the average american professor okay
i think charles blow
has done blacks more harm than almost
any living writer
he teaches his kids in his own columns
he teaches his kids that whites
hate to hate them is that a lie or is
that a lie
i'm a jew if i taught my jewish kids
that
christians hate them i would be doing
the biggest
uh disservice to my children it's a form
of child abuse
to raise a black kid to think whites
hate him he's abused his children
charles blog
dennis as a fellow member of the tribe
mot
why do 75 percent of jewish people vote
democrat what's wrong with them
american jewry has uh has
become an embarrassment to this jew who
has done so much for judaism i wrote the
most widely used
introduction to judaism in the english
language the most widely used commentary
on the torah
at this time uh i founded a synagogue at
jewish day school
i i was a leader in the soviet jewry
movement i am embarrassed by my fellow
uh
75 percent of my fellow jews who have
traded in judaism
uh for leftism that is their new
religion the jews who believe in the
torah are orthodox and they vote uh
they vote republican so at what point
did it
i guess did it change for me because i i
mean i'm wondering this myself
why do so many blacks vote democrat
other than republicans because they they
just like the jews they have accepted
uh the brainwash that uh that
conservatives hate them
donald trump has done more for the jews
than any president uh
virtually any president of my lifetime
and uh
60 of israeli jews support trump of
israel's jews interesting isn't it not
american jews are unique
in their leftism unique wow
you have a follow-up with that adam i
mean that you you you had that question
so maybe you've got to follow up as a
fellow jew yeah well obviously if you're
a orthodox jew you tend to be more
conservative
that's
that's correct i agree which makes the
case for religion doesn't it
you